farmer does have experience against
these los angeles angels of anaheim he's
faced him seven times three of those
games have been starts he's got a great
era at 2.78 batting average against him
is 183 for the angels i'll bring up mike
trout here it comes
and that is over for strike three with
the curve ball and trout goes down
looking ending over next astros farm
hand will be going against his former
organization it'll be the third time he
does so he is 0-1 in two previous starts
with a 5.68 era
springer first pitch swinging sends one
to right joe adele almost misplays it in
right field but he leaps up and makes
the catch springer never let go of the
bat that almost got over adele's head
that fooled dell out there maybe he
didn't think it was hit as hard as it
was but at the same time it's another
demonstration on how poorly the luck has
been for george springer
so two out and a runner on for justin
upton payoff pitch
and that is on the inside corner for
strike three with the curve ball of
upton and valdez picks up his third
strikeout strands a runner at first base
rendon a lead off hit but that's all
tucker hitting 240 287 on base
percentage for homer's 20 rbis coming
off a great road trip hit 471
and that's hammered pretty well the
right center field adele on this horse
looking up see you later into the astros
bullpen for kyle tucker's fifth home run
of the year one-nothing astros he's
swinging a good on the road trip now
he's just tripping all the way around
the bases after that line drive into the
bullpen of the astros in right center
field
107.7 miles an hour off the bat josh
redick at the plate
line drive over the head of simmons
that's going to score a run yuli will be
waved around no play on him reddick's
going to break it down he thought about
two but he will settle for an rbi single
josh redick stays hot in the month of
august it's two nothing good battle in
that at bat for josh reddick to end up
with that rbi base hit
then boom around the butt and he'll let
it go for mayfield how about jack
mayfield starting his first major league
game at third base and he makes a fine
defensive play super jack a heck of a
play coming in charging with the bare
hand man in scoring position for david
fletcher oh two to david
chopper to the right side guriel
gonna take it himself it's a foot race
and safe at first infield base hit
valdez never covered the run scores
that's an infield base hit and an rbi 21
houston well we talked a lot about
little ball that was uh definitely small
ball 49 pitches in 26 strikes not the
ratio sandoval wants a couple of walks
in this inning fully goes the other way
and fletcher will make the play to
second nobody covering first and the
throw is made to first base and it gets
by albert paul wasn't on the bag and he
turned around to simmons and say why did
you throw that because nobody was
covering the bag and altuve scores on
the error well i'll tell you what
veterans can make
bonehead mistakes too because this
entire play is in front of andrelton
simmons he just turned and fired with
here's brantley guriel on second
and bradley sends one down the line and
right that'll be down for a hit and
that'll score a run michael brandley
digging for two as yuley crosses the
plate it's a 4-1 astros lead nice piece
of hitting from uncle mike it's good to
see him out there changing tires again
for the astros here's josh reddick who's
single the other way the pitch and
that's hit into right field that's a
base hit redick with a single knocks in
michael brantley and the astros lead
five to one and another two out rbi for
the astros that's epic so they're gonna
have to get their bullpen up and that's
brutal before a double header don't
think oh yeah four strikeouts now for
farmer here's justin upton who struck
out looking his last time up
hits this one out to right field hit
pretty well reddick moving back and near
the wall gone big fly for justin up to
the solo shot going the opposite way and
it's five to two up its third of the
year fastball away just went with it how
strong he is just like that the engine
is only down by three now
the trout able to draw the walk that's
the second allowed by fromber there are
two on for anthony rendon breaking ball
back toward the middle and that is going
to be a base hit off the glove of altuve
trickles out into center field fletcher
will score trout ends up at third and
rbi is single it's now a 5-3 game that
ball almost
stopped by altuve but just eluded him
now two runners on with two outs and
albert pool holds the batter an rbi just
90 feet away we'll be able to pass alex
rodriguez in the all-time rbi list pulse
is able to pick up a hit
albert pulls this one to the left field
there it is passes alex rodriguez with
that single a little bit of a bobble
there by tucker rendon will take third
congrats on that one albert second
all-time now by himself moves him in the
second place all time and runs batted in
since rbi's became an official stat in
1920 one rbi more than alex rodriguez
correa's over three he is grounded out
all three times redick will be off third
maldonado off second and straw off first
following the gap should clear everybody
that ball hooked down the line and that
ball is fair ball into the corner straw
speed will score easily three run double
for carlos correa and the astros now
lead eight to four
and now jason castro will get to hit he
came on the catch last inning with bim
boom moving to the mound
and that should do it it does as the tag
is made by stub c l strikes out jason
castro to end the game